[Music]
the third episode of the mandalorian
second season chapter 11 the heiress was
a seafaring and stormtrooper zapping
good
time the fair amount of easter eggs and
callbacks tucked away for fans to find
here are a few you may have missed the
heiress brought mando and his little
green friend to the never before seen
watery moon
trask completing their mission to
deliver frog lady and her eggs back to
her husband
credited here as frogman after a very
bumpy landing and an assist from a crane
machine that might just be a repurposed
imperial walker we got a closer look at
the resonance of trask
both the quarren and the mon calamari
species joined the star wars universe in
return of the jedi
although they appeared in very different
places the quorum hung out with jabba
the hutt while the film introduced the
mon calamari as key members of the
rebellion during the battle of endor
the most famous among them is the
legendary admiral akbar who remained a
part of the faction until he died in the
last jedi
additionally a season 4 arc from the
clone wars put their conflict on the
homeworld of mancala
front and center plus rogue one also
bolstered the mon calamari standing in
the rebellion's ranks with the
introduction of admiral raddus
for both species the heiress isn't their
first appearance in the mandalorian
in the opening scene of the series
premiere a quarren was seen being sliced
in half by a door
grief karga also offered mando a mon
calamari bounty in episode 3.
plus in the heiress mando finally uses
the mon calamari money karga gave him
way back in the very first episode
after chartering a ship to go find more
mandalorians mando and the child are
betrayed by their quarren sea captain
thankfully they're rescued in short
order from a new creature known as a
mamacore by a group of blue and
grey-clad mandalorians
we know from the clone wars that these
are the night owls led by fan favorite
bocatan crees
bokutan is played by battlestar
galactica's katie sakhoff for the first
time in live action
and she's the heiress from the title a
nod to her past as the ruler of
mandalore
bogotan arrived in the star wars
universe during the fourth season of the
clone wars
with sakhoff also voicing her as death
watch leader pree vizsla's right-hand
woman
prie vizsla by the way was voiced by
mandalorian showrunner john favreau
we know from the season one finale of
the mandalorian that mando was rescued
by death watch members as a child
with pree vizsla's later demise at the
hands of darth maul bogatan and a group
of mandalorians split off from the
faction and formed the mandalore
resistance
playing an integral role in the siege of
mandalore during the clone wars season
7.
following the fall of the galactic
empire bokotan's exploits were shrouded
in relative mystery as her story dropped
off after a brief appearance in rebels
however it appears that the mandalorian
will rectify that finally giving
audiences the answers they desire about
her whereabouts and motives in a
post-imperial world
in the mandalorian season one finale mop
gideon used an ancient mandalorian
darksaber to cut through the wreckage of
his downed tie fighter to escape
since that moment viewers have wondered
how exactly this top-ranking imperial
official wound up with the artifact
before its re-emergence however boko tan
was the last person shown wielding it in
star wars rebels after fellow
mandalorian sabine wren handed it over
to her
any specifics detailing how she lost it
however have yet to come to light
there is something i need if i am to
rule mandalore something that was once
mine the heiress went a long way in
solving this mystery through a bit of
key dialogue from boca tan that hints to
a previously untold star wars story
after she and her crew fight their way
to the bridge of an imperial shuttle
bogatan interrogates the head officer
played by titus welliber the third actor
from hbo's deadwood to appear this
season following timothy olyphant and w
earl brown
bokutan doesn't get any information out
of him before he takes his own life
but she does allude to some kind of
shared history between herself and
gideon
asking the officer to take her to him
without actually naming him
hopefully the show will expand more on
how the weapon slipped from her hands
into gideon's at some point after her
rebels cameo
after successfully hijacking an imperial
gozanti cruiser ship a model first
spotted in the phantom menace
mano departs to continue his mission of
delivering the child to its people
but not before asking his fellow
mandalorian where he can find the jedi
she claimed to know
grateful for his aid bogatan tells him
to travel to the city of kaladan on the
forest planet of corvus
a new location for the star wars
universe so who is this
jedi on corvus another animated favorite
ahsoka tano the debut of anakin
skywalker's former padawan and live
action has been a long time coming with
speculation over rosario dawson's
casting as ahsoka running rampant for
months
and the circumstances surrounding her
imminent arrival couldn't be more
satisfying for die hard star wars fans
you should have seen him in person
anakin skywalker
he was my master having initially
squared off his enemies bokutan and
ahsoka
allied during the siege of mandalore as
detailed on clone wars seventh season
once the jedi order disbanded and order
66 went into full effect leading ahsoka
to go into hiding the status of their
coalition grew murky
but it seems that they retained some
method of contact throughout the
galactic civil war and in the midst of
the empire's collapse
also much like boca tan ahsoka's
adventures continued through rebels
where she took up the code name fulcrum
and became a secret rebel operative
her vape beyond the series finale was a
mystery for a long time but it's likely
the mandalorian's 12th chapter will
finally fill in some of the
long-standing blanks in her story
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mandalorian are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one